boa tarde a todos
é um prazer estar aqui e poder
compartilhar um pouco a história do
nosso projeto e espero que de alguma
maneira isso possa servir para inspirar
vocês abraçaram a causa desses acreditam
assim como a gente fez é começou em 2010
antes de começar a falar da primeira
chance acho que vale a pena fazer a
provocação pra vocês
e aí eu vou pedir licença para usar o
exemplo do guilherme dos 10 reais
a provocação é a seguinte vocês sabiam e
vocês acreditam que com dez reais por
dia
você consegue mudar a vida de um jovem
tira ele da favela e colocar numa melhor
escola de engenharia do brasil é mesmo
modo nosso projeto e espero contar a
história vocês acreditem possam bom
fazer aparecer pra começar
acho que ela quer dizer como é que
surgiu a idéia da primeira chance a
primeira chance surgiu a partir da
constatação que a gente tinha a respeito
de alguns círculos sociais que têm de
aprisionar as pessoas determinados
segmentos sociais que é então
então todo mundo vai concordar com isso
mas aqui no brasil o estudante de um de
baixa renda à família de baixa renda
dele tende a ir à escola que não é boa e
ele tende a não acessaram a faculdade de
ponta e por consequência não vai ter um
bom emprego o filho dele vai ajudar a
escola pública de novo então existe um
ciclo que tem de aprisionar essa geração
aí a mesma forma se primeira vez se as
pessoas que nasceram família de boa
renda
ele vai com a escola de ponta a partir
daí ele vai ter acesso a uma educação de
qualidade e vai levar ele em tese a
universidade boa e aí por conseqüência
bons empregos e o filho dele vai também
da escola particular
então olhando é difícil você encontrar e
é muito pontual quando acontece uma
pessoa me grade 15 o outro
a primeira chance então e identificando
esse padrão o nosso objetivo era em taji
dando uma educação de qualidade pra ver
se a gente conseguir quebrar esse circo
e aí pergunto de baixa renda da educação
de qualidade pra ele e ver onde vai
chegar ver se de fato a gente consegue
transformar a vida dele de maneira
diferente é bom tom e assim começou em
2010 ea primeira chance surgiu com o
objetivo de mudar de estação brasil eu
tinha 12 anos não cabe a mim é o co
fundador do projeto é a gente criar um
desenvolvimento que mudar sim acho que
isso é uma conseqüência
o projeto vem sendo assim é mas a gente
conseguiu mudar a vida de um cara bom
claro conseguiu jogar basta escolher
quem é esse cara
então já que tinha escala número de
pessoas que a gente ajudar a gente tem
só vão ajudar alguém e tem um enorme
potencial
a expectativa é de que ele vai fazer um
bom uso disso dessa investimento em
educação e ele vai bem longe e vai
ajudar muita gente e vamos ter contato
com ele ao longo do caminho
a gente definiu dois filhos primeiro
carlos e carente
segundo eles é muito bom assim começou a
música é muito fácil
o são paulo pode já ter começado em
fortaleza
eu sou ea identificação com a terra
então a gente foi atrás de um carro
muito bom e como toda a pesquisa
na verdade nosso carro ela começou no
google tinha google à noite ao chegar do
trabalho
o aluno escola pública carente pobre bom
medalha foi juntando uma lista de até
oito potenciais ou se tinha 8 a abordar
também definiu que a gente ia dar pra
ele
basicamente tudo o que precisava
preencher objeto de licitação então é
uma escola mensalidade da escola de
ponta alimentação moradia e transporte é
relacionado a ele estudar desenvolver
esse potencial dele
o projeto começou assim a gente legal e
era um estranho é o pedro foi matemático
total desconfiar que quer ter acesso a
uma educação de qualidade
o colégio vai pagar a gente vai dar
moradia transporte e alimentação
material um tutor pode acompanhar a
carreira tudo isso de graça
o emprego trabalhar para você mesmo
os quatro da lista e eles contaram à mãe
a mãe dizia ter fugido né não vai pra
escola mágico em alguém procurando já
sabe até que ser bom em matemática
isto é verdade até que teve um cara que
ele já voltava de uma casa alexandre e
ele não queria começar por lá porque
ponte açúcar fortalecer já ia ter mais
trabalho aí banho está o projeto comigo
há um ano e meio pra gente fãs não
existe pra ele e alexandre montado em
matemática foi no olímpico brasileiro
sequer um colégio melhor de fortaleza dá
acesso à alimentação deficiente moradia
um tutor que acompanha a carreira de
graça se quer tudo isso e passaram se
três anos
o resultado disso nosso objetivo era
quebrar aquele circo social e ver se a
gente conseguir ter ajudado carlos
alexandre maneira sustentável avalia um
pouco de chegar obviamente no começo o
desafio gente e não tinha muita certeza
de onde ele então tinha problema e
receio de não se adaptar e ele não
reclama também do nível dele não ser tão
bom ele não conseguir acompanhar mas deu
certo
alexandre na primeira chance em três
anos ele ganhou 11 olimpíadas de
matemática
ele passou não é comprovado no mp para a
seletiva mundial de matemática
representar o brasil na olimpíada
platense
ele era a nossa seleção e matemática é o
nosso lema
e deu certo e agora se preparam para itu
e eu não tenho dúvida vai passar se não
passa lá passa em um outro quarto de
ponto ele vai ter acesso a bons empregos
a família dele eo filho de rute da
escola de excelência e aqueles ciclos e
quebrou a gente ficou legal com taxa
para as pessoas
só quando a gente contava o pessoal
falava assim sorte muito problema
não eu estou curioso que era sorte né
vão tentar um segundo segundo ele não é
o enderson
ele não é campeão
automático é na verdade ele descobrir
nosso projeto o que a gente da matéria
do valor econômico fala que está
procurando alunos carentes de fortaleza
e com símbolos de alguns e uma moça que
trabalhava no banco do brasil mandou e
mail a hora do ala particular de
matemática a comunidade tem um lindo
espetáculo tem uma caçamba de beberibe e
agente ligou pra ele trouxe ele fez
processo as notas não foram boas mas a
gente queria muito assim como o wn
enchia se ligava pra gente o que ela
quer participar mas até então a gente
estava ainda selecionando a entrevista
a gente perguntava querer entender o
candidato nessa de um pouco a realidade
dele as perspectivas como é que foi a
vida dele ea gente perguntou onde mora o
caucaia ce na verdade tocarem mora ele
deveria beber e inglês
o programa de intercâmbio londres não
existe sentido eu achei que estava na
rua e 10 anos de idade na praia demora
ele viu os gringos estranha inglês
sim mas um casal que morava do lado da
minha avó e eles estavam na comunidade
eu falei vou ficar curioso foi o inglês
básico história toda agora em inglês
a apresentação a primeira chance em
inglês e em português inglês espanhol ou
alemão nem mas ninguém sabe quem está
aqui e deixar falar alemão acredita
nessa ir embora
e foi isso o carro ainda não entrou no
projeto mesma coisa 3 anos educação de
qualidade comentou oficialmente carreira
alimentação decente moradia e os
resultados são guardian
ronei ficou em segundo lugar geral do
spectrum das faculdades de 90 de
economia do brasil ganhou bolsa integral
o dos patrocinadores do item abraçaram e
levar ele pra são paulo e ele está sendo
hoje disputar o banco de investimento o
investimento das maiores empresas do
brasil
ele está vendo ele aprendendo a cuidar
então o primeiro sorte
segundo ela falava só que por cada um
que é campeão de matemática
segundo a mãe do bebê então você tem
muita soja acontecer é o terceiro a
cassiopéia seu pai é o seguinte não tem
resultados de limpeza que chama atenção
é também aprender inglês livre e mas é
um excelente aluna sua esforçada e
identificamos dizendo seleção de
conhecer três anos de qualidade mentor
financeiramente carneiro alimentação
deficiente moradia são iguais
ela passou 11 passou passou no exterior
você integral foi morar lá
no primeiro semestre dela que agora
acabou primeiro semestre
ela foi o primeiro lugar geral do início
então os efeitos que houve enormes e não
tenho dúvida a canção pé no chão em 31
daqui a pouco vamos ao campo grande está
um grande companhia volta ficando
reverter esse benefício que eles tiveram
o em seu pé já participou de um grupo no
ensaio chamado de nazista que ajuda a
comunidade e da aula de graças a alguns
parentes querem entrar no índice
então você vai ver que o efeito
multiplicador do projeto mas a gente
teve sorte uma sorte duas vezes só três
vezes e aí ou nunca tive tanta sorte
assim na minha paixão menino tinha muita
sorte mesmo
e aí a gente encontrou 23 o projeto hoje
está aí e aí que a história só falta mas
só existem mais história e você tem que
contar mas todos eles têm o mesmo perfil
em todos os seus mesmos resultados
o perfil é um perfil carente muito bom
aí o pessoal pergunta quanto carente e é
muito caro
a renda familiar média 600 reais em
alguns de nós que a gente esperava foi o
fardamento uniforme ligou pra ele
perguntou qual a qual número do sapato
por não sair no seu sapato
eu sou muito carente e os resultados são
excepcionais também aprovou no início e
escola militar passou no vestibular do
if tem um cara até o rodrigo é a segunda
da última coluna ele é baiano teve bons
resultados e olimpíadas 2012 mesmo
processo
só que em um ano ele gostou do resultado
em um ano ele foi aprovado um programa
com a universidade harvard programa de
jovens talentos
lá dentro ele foi eleito um monstro a
frase dele o mais provável de ser
presidente e todo o grupo de talentosos
todo mundo queria conhecer ea partir daí
desencadeou vários outros projetos foi
aprovado em erro para justificar o fato
não consiga chegar mas pode vir a ser um
grande e pode vir a ser um presidente e
um projeto de impacto mas a vida de 1
230 23 já começa a afetar as pessoas em
vários casos aqui o interessante é o que
a mudança de perspectiva do carro
isso é o primeiro pacto que você vê
alexandre com ele e perguntar o que
fazer e que ninguém conhece ninguém faz
faculdade que tá beleza três meses
depois do projeto
liguei pra ele aí casa já está bem
adaptada total bem e aí está pensando em
alguma coisa na faculdade tona por
decidir o que vamos bater fundo três
meses depois dos seis meses depois o
projeto só seis meses
a gente vai falar com ele de novo ele
falou rapaz não vai fazer não é uma
favorita que não se adaptou vai voltar
pra montada não quer mais estudar assim
não que isto é fácil descobrir que o
momento é o limite
eu falei assim cara não sabe escrever
mas xuxa escreve massachusetts aí que dá
uma boa estatura e mas é isso essa
mudança de perspectiva global ligada a
um carro legal
ele está no primeiro ano com a gente
agora e ea gente conversava com ele
pergunta por que quero fazer missões ele
tinha
agora ele ligou pra ele falou assim tudo
bom o que bater pa está acontecendo há
algum problema
aliás o primeiro lugar dele é no colégio
é ele foi melhor assim tá pensando aqui
aquela pergunta vocês fizeram e resposta
umar tem que fazer muito contato e
fazendo contato com você e aí isso e
então a perspectiva não mudando e isso é
interessante você vai ver que eles vão
acreditando neles mesmo bom som
toda geração assim como todo o processo
seletivo nosso tem um talento toda
geração quem talento do futebol pelé
nasceu aqui futebol clube x que
acompanha ele dá treinamento e fiquei lá
enquanto durar o jogo no futebol é óbvio
que esse cara vai perguntar mas não
contra a rússia que também lá sim é esse
processo
o objetivo da primeira chance então é
expandir um pouco isso ea gente começará
até campos de várzea
não só no futebol mas também pela escola
carioca alexandre faria com uma temática
de cabeça que há que estar atento é
óbvio que ele é muito bom
só que não era feito nada a partir daí é
existem uma série de olimpíadas
resultado e e análise de escola pública
que realmente mapeiam os alunos e dizem
os bons talentos do brasil do senado
feita na página 9 milhões de estudantes
fazem exames em escola pública e eles
são super bem mas não sou muito bem
detalhadamente avaliava só depois disso
nada é feito
e aí a gente resolveu expandir a gente
cria um projeto de madrugada e ímpar na
primeira chance que basicamente o
seguinte a gente começou a compilar
informações e resultados e olimpíadas de
todo o brasil
a gente vê o quanto e de talento a gente
tem no país
e a gente tem uma plataforma que junta
todos esses dados é quando vão funcionar
um filtro se pode dizer aonde você quer
procurar o bolsista é grande mapa de
talentos do brasil ea partir daí a gente
começou a levar a primeira chance não só
com o ceará não só pra o novo 10 mas por
todo o brasil e tem espantado a gente é
que de fato nosso país é muito rico
então ele é impressionante o número de
talentos de jovens com potencial que a
gente encontra em cada processo de
seleção
então assim pra finalizar conta a
história da primeira chance mas o acho
que a mensagem importante já foi
discutido aqui é que o tek serve para
espalhar a idéia e eu acho que a
mensagem se você acredita em uma causa
você acha que dá para mudar a realidade
não precisa pensar em mudar o brasil
como um todo pode pensar da senhora de
um cara e com isso o caminho o projeto
vai ganhar mais consistência você vai
gostar você vai mais pessoas madrid na
causa quando você ver se consigo alguma
coisa um pouco maior
a gente começou o dia 22 anos a
bolsa-estágio trabalho eo google
depois disso o projeto cresceu então
gente conseguiu um tipo no mundo
consegue é mais ou menos isso que a
gente queria falar obrigado